في رمضان تفاعلكم مركز معاكم مشاهدينا على
الدراما والمسلسلات لكن اليوم اسمحوا لنا
نعمل استثناء فبعيدا عن المسلسلات في فيلم
شغال الان ما فينا نتجاهله ابدا وفيلم
ينفع نسميه فيلم الموسم نحن بنتكلم طبعا
عن الموضوع الابرز والاول على مختلف
الشاشات والعناوين اليوم استدعاء الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دون الترامب الى المحكمه
اليوم لتوجيه التهم رسميا في قضيه شاغل
العالم كله خلينا نبدا حلقتنا اليوم مثل
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب امام
محكمه منهات في نيويورك لابلاغه رسميا
بتوجيه تهم جنائيه ضد في قضيه بدات باخبار
انه دفع اموال لممثله افلام اباحيه لشراء
صمتها عن علاقه سابقه جمعتهم الممثله اللي
بنتكلم عنها هي ستورميدانز واسمها الحقيقي
ستيفاني كليفورد في 2006 يعني قبل سنوات
من ترشحه للرئاسه كان في اشاعات عن علاقه
بين ترامب وبينها وفي طلعت اخبار عن حوار
مرتقب عن العلاقه اجرى دستورمين مع او
اجره دستور في 2011 تحديدا مع احدى
المجلات لكن لاحقا ما انتشر الحوار او مد
نشر الحوار وقال الناس انه السبب انه
محامي ترامب السابق اللي هو مايكل هدد
بمقاداتها راحت السنين وبعد سنوات في 2018
فجرت صحيفه
المفاجاه عن العلاقه وقالت انه يا جماعه
قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه في 2016
دفع 130 الف دولار للممثله هذه علشان ما
تفشي سر العلاقه بينهم ووقتها في 2016 كان
بالضبط قبل الانتخابات فتره ما كان يبغى
فضائح وتشويش يعني وقيل او قبل انه محامي
يكون يدفع لها 130 الف دولار ولاحقا اعترف
محامي ترامب السابق مع الكوبون بدفع
المبلغ من ماله الخاص التوجيه من ترامب
لاحقا ترامب رجع الفلوس لكون وكتبها في
سجلات الماليه انها اتعاب قضائيه وهنا
المشكله ومربط الفرس في هذه القضيه الفلوس
هذه مو اتعاب محاماه بعد ما اعترفكم باللي
صار طلعت فيه مقابله مع برنامج وروت القصه
كامله وكشفت تفاصيل صادمه وقالت انها
تعرفت على ترامب في نادي الجولف في 2006
ودعاها للعشاء في غرفته بالفندق وبتقول
انه صارت بينهم علاقه جنسيه وانا تعرضت
للتهديد من بدايات خروج القضيه للاعلام
وانها فكرت في 2011 انها تبيع القضيه لما
جل مقابل 15 الف دولار لكن في رجل مجهول
هددها بابنتها وعائلتها وهدد كمان بمقاضاه
المجله وانه محامي ترامب اجبرها في 2016
على توقيع اتفاقيه صمت وانه في حال
انتهاكها حتدفع غرامه ضخمه واعطاها 130
الف دولار علشان تسكت وطبعا كل هذه
الروايات مشاهدينا ترامب بينفيها وبيقول
انها مو صحيحه وانه هو ما ارتكب اي مخالفه
للقوانين وانه اصلا من 2018 اكون ما عاد
محامين طيب بالعوده للحاضر الان هذه القصه
مع شراء صمته كانت او صمته كانت مفتاح
القضيه الحاليه ضده واللي فيها اتهامات
بدفع رشوه لسيده اخرى وايضا انتهاك قوانين
الحملات الانتخابيه كعاده ترامب توجه
لمنصته
لمؤخرا هي ميلاده في كل شيء بيصير معه ومن
قبل ما يوصل نيويورك كان بدا يكتب بوستات
واحد ورا الثاني فكتب قبل ما يغادر بوست
قال فيه انه هو راح يسافر الاثنين الى
نيويورك وقال انه صدقوا او لا تصدقوا راح
اروح الى قاعه المحكمه وقال انه مو مفترض
تكون امريكا بهذا الحال ومن بعد الى
نيويورك نشر بوست جديد قال فيه انه مدعي
عام
سرب لائحه الاتهام هذه وهذا غير قانوني
ولازم الان المدعي العام نفسه توجه لتهم
ورجع اضاف في بوست ثاني انه المدعي العام
بنفسه تسرب 33 نقطه من لائحه الاتهام وقال
هذه فوضى ولازم المدعي العام يستقيل ومن
بعدها صعد لهجته ضد برافو وصفه بالمجنون
اليساري الراديكالي وقال انه لازم يستقيل
فورا واما اخر بوست او اخر بوست كان نشروا
ترمط من ساعات فطالب في بنقل مكان
المحاكمه من مكانها الحالي الى او اللي هي
تعتبر مكانها الحالي هي منطقه 1% فيها بس
جمهوريين طلب بنقل المحاكمه الى جزيره
ستاتن ايلاند في نيويورك ايضا لانها موقع
عادل وامن جدا للمحاكمه
طيب كل اللي ذكرته سابقا ملخص بسيط والله
للقصه تعالوا الان نتكلم سوا في اللي صار
اليوم تحديدا ترامب الموجود في نيويورك
توجه لي المحكمه في منهاجا طلع من ترامبور
وسط استنفار امني مشدد ووصل الى المحكمه
وكان في المئات من انصاره متجمعين في
المكان ورافعين شعارات بتدعموا وبتدعم
ترشحه الانتخابات عشرين اربعه وعشرين وتم
النقل على لسان ترامب وهو داخل للمحكمه
قوله
سيعتقلونني لا اصدق ذلك
[موسيقى]
سجلات تجاريه وكمان تامر وامامكم على
الشاشه الان الوثيقه الرسميه للتهم
الموجهه ضده
طبعا ترامب طبعا نفه كل الاتهامات هذه ومن
بعدها اخلي سبيل وبدون شروط وغادر المحكمه
الى مطار لاغوارديال العوده الى فلوريدا
واللي راح يتوجه منها بكلمه لانصاره خلال
ساعات كلمه طبعا مرتقبه من قبل الكثيرين
معنى من نيويورك مكتب العربيه في واشنطن
ناديه البلبيسي اهلا فيك معنا يا ناديه
يوم حافل صراحه بالاحداث كيف كانت رده
الفعل والمشهد وراك عند المحكمه وما الى
ذلك بعد خصوصا بعد حديث المدعي العام
وخروج التهم للعلن
مساء الخير ساره اول شيء كنت استمع في
الواقع للسرد كان شيق جدا ودقيق جدا بكل
ما ذكرتيه حتى الان وطبعا عنوانكم رائع يا
ناديه وكل مذنب بريء حتى اكيد اكيد
عنوان هذا الفيلم هو المذنب وكل مذنب
بريئه حتى تثبت اذانتو طبعا الرئيس هذه
نهايه الفن لا نعرف اذا كانت ستكون سعيده
بالكامل اي
القاضي سيغلق هذه القضيه لانه الان بدانا
بدانا نسمع ردود الافعال وفي الواقع لم
يكن هناك مفاجات يعني كان هناك تشويق لكن
لم يكن هناك مفاجات بانه كنا نعرف بان
رئيس اتهم بدفع هذه الاموال 130 الف دولار
كنا نعرف عن المراه الاخرى ايضا وهي كارين
مجدودو لكن ايضا ربما هذا الشخص الاخير
العام الذي كان في برجه وحاول ان يكسب
وايضا لكن كل هذا في اطار الحمله
الانتخابيه وتزوير بعض الوثائق الى اخره
هناك شعور ربما بخيبه الامل من قبل بعض
الاشخاص الذين كانوا يريدون بالفعل ان
يكون هناك دليل اقوى ضد الرئيس ترامب وان
يتم ادانته طبعا هو ذهب الى مرا لارج هو
سنرى طبعا لانه هو سيد اقتناص الفرص هو
يحول كل الازمات الى فرص والى
مصلحته يعني سواء كانت المصلحه الانتخابيه
بجمع الاموال او بحشد مؤيديه وراينا قبل
قليل كل ردود الافعال من الجمهورين
بالتحديد وخصوصا من منتقدين مثل السنه
غير مؤهل لان يكون رئيس الولايات المتحده
ويختلف معهم في كل النواحي وخصوصا موضوع
اخلاقي لانه هو رجل محافظ يقيم
المبادئ الاسريه وغيرها اتحدث
على ترامب ومن هنا يقول هذا الادعاء هو
مسيس
ويوافق الجمهوريين ثلثي الامريكيين الذين
يروا بان السياسه لعبه دور بالفعل في هذه
القضيه وان
الفنبراج وهو المدعي العام الذي اصبح
شهيرا الان توعدت رمح حتى قبل ان ياتي الى
هذه المحكمه منذ سنوات عندما ترشح يعني
على سيره موضوع اللي بتقوليه ناديه انه هو
سيد اقتناص فرص الان في عاجل على الشاشه
يعني انه ترامب بيقول انه اعود الى وانا
واثق اكثر من اي وقت مضى باننا سنفوز
بالرئاسه يعني بيقول انه يعني كانكم انتم
خدمتوني الان خدمه العمر يعني
يعني يفوز بالرئاسه لا اعرف يعني لن اراهن
على فوزه بالرئاسه لكن استطيع ان اقول
بانه قد يفوز بترشح الحزب الجمهوري هناك
انتخابات تمهيديه وهناك شخص ينافس ترامب
وهو حاكم
اكثر حظا يعني لا نتحدث
والسابق ولا غيرها من الاسماء حتى لكن
بالفعل هناك تاييد للترامب ب 90% واكثر في
داخل حزب الجمهوري لكن بالنسبه للمستقلين
وبالنسبه للمشككين وبالنسبه للمعارضين
لترامب كل سجله بما فيه لا اعتقد بانه
كافيه لاقناعهم بالتصويت له في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه طيب
ناديه كيف كانت الاوضاع الامنيه يعني كان
قبل من ايام وهي نيويورك بتستعد امنيا
الله
يبدو صار عندك شيء
بالضبط هذا موكب
الان يمر ربما هو تمام لا مش ترامب لا
المدعي العامه خلص راح
بس
مدعي العام ممكن بس كان فيه قبل اسابيع من
اسبوع صاروا بيستعدوا وبيتكلموا عن
الاستعدادات الامنيه هل صارت اي مشاكل او
اي شيء من هذا القبيل
لا كل الاجراءات الامنيه كانت احترازيه
بالدرجه الاولى اولا حتى لا نرى سيناريو
يتكرر في نيويورك كما حدث في واشنطن مع
انه المشابهه والمقاربه مختلفه تماما في
ذلك الوقت كان هناك عشرات الالاف من
مؤيدين رئيس ترامب وانا اذكر كنت امام
مبنى الكابيتال في ذلك اليوم على اساس
انها مظاهرات سلميه لكنها تحولت الى عنيفه
اقتحام للمبنى الذي هزه الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه والدخول الى مكتب خمس اشخاص
يعني في النهايه لكن هنا 30 الف عنصر من
الشرطه ومن الاف بي اي ومن الحرس الوطني
لا احد يستطيع ان يتحرك بعض المشدات
الكلاميه البسيطه بين اتباع ترامب والذين
يناهضوها او الذين تظاهروا ضده ببعض
الشعارات لكن لم نرى وجود كبير لمناصري
الرئيس والقضيه مختلفه يعني الاولى كانت
يعني التشكيت في انتخابات ويعني الامل
بعوده ترامب كرئيس الول المتحده في ذلك
الوقت بتحدي النتائج ونتحدث الان عن اتهام
لدفع للممثله اباحيه نعم طيب ناديه نحن
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله معنا واطلاعنا
على الاوضاع عندكم طبعا انا عارفه انه
يومك طويل وحيستمر هذا اليوم طويل فيعطيك
العافيه كل انت وكل فريق العربيه طبعا في
امريكا شكرا لك كانت معنا من نيويورك
مديره مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ناديه
البلبيسي
[موسيقى]